last winter the stars alive for the
first ever Celebrity Big Brother now
it's happening okay CBS announced the
new cast of Celebrity Big Brother and
viewers are in for a treat thank you the
Pens like a bomb I've only had one other
course in my life
[Music]
breathe missed mr you're not breathing
remember your breath in today's day and
age with debit cards and credit cards
and all this craft fewer and fewer
people are paying with cash
I should just pay with something smaller
since it's only five dollars okay having
fun time filming the sequel to force Cup
sir its stranger's voice really is it's
that there's a sick devotee voices yeah
sort of chilling it definitely gives me
confidence and I think swimming has
helped me through that on you know being
on like Serna like a center stage of
like being on like at the Olympics being
on the highest stage in sports and being
up like at the top it does give you
confidence just as usual what who are
you wearing I'm Rachel Stewart
absolutely beautiful
allow yourself to be seduced daesil how
comes you those people including
yourself never seem to prevail upon the
president he's gonna continue to say
these things so he has a very unique
operating style and let's I'll seed
every single point on the table and I do
watch your show I'm a fan of the show
and let's say everything he says is a
lie that's still missing the message of
what he has to at least half of the
United States is french fries here take
mine
take my meatloaf too but don't stop
there take my shirt take my room the air
out of my Wong's open my mouth thanks
buddy
these a do of Celebrity Big Brother
premieres January 21st on CBS
[Music]